[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 una
iniciativa innovadora para promover la
perspectiva de género en las vías
argentinas ya está en vigencia quienes
aspiren a obtener una licencia de
conducir deberán tomar como parte del
proceso un curso de género la medida se
aplica desde el 7 de julio de este año y
el curso que es obligatorio ya está
disponible en todos los centros en los
que se obtiene el permiso para manejar
los estereotipos nos han llevado a
popularizar por muchos años de creencias
como que las mujeres son conductoras
torpes o que los hombres son menos
propensos a sufrir agresiones en la vida
según la agencia nacional de seguridad
vial o fueron identificadas esas
visiones discriminatorias que deben
cambiar nuestro corresponsal en
argentina natale ojos hoy nos cuenta más
desde buenos aires
y viviendo porque sabe que soy mujer y
no me voy a bajar a pelear esta
capacitación de género en vídeo es ahora
un paso obligatorio que deben cumplir
los aspirantes a obtener una licencia de
conducir en argentina su objetivo es
poner en evidencia los prejuicios y los
estereotipos de género en el espacio del
tránsito vehícular estereotipos y
prejuicios que dicen que las mujeres son
menos capaces de conducir este prejuicio
hacia las mujeres tienen consecuencias
en la vida cotidiana
hace que muchas mujeres que podrían
sacar la licencia no lo hagan por temor
a la mirada del varón por temor a pasar
situaciones de violencia en la vía
pública por temor a la discriminación
jimena palmas forma parte de quienes por
primera vez reciben este curso para
obtener su primera licencia de conducir
tú bueno la verdad nunca lo había
pensado desde ese lado se ha pensando
este las reglas de tránsito de estas
cosas a partir del género y estaba está
bueno porque nada nos hace pensar así
que bienvenidos
justamente qué piensan los hombres de
que haya un curso como éste creo que las
perspectivas género tendrían que ser
obligatorias en muchos ámbitos de la
vida y no solamente para sacar una
matrícula de conducir nada porque hay
una cuestión temperamental que no va de
acuerdo o digamos no está en relación
con algún curso que uno puede hacer
porque uno tiene que hacer un curso de
de género posiblemente porque los
hombres son locos y en la calle le
gritan de todas las mujeres pensando que
las mujeres solamente sirven para
cocinar y no sirven para marcar
seguramente por eso y si uno se guía por
las estadísticas es todo lo contrario
porque a pesar de todos los prejuicios
sobre las mujeres al volante ellas son
responsables de menos siniestros graves
y son más respetuosas de las reglas de
tránsito para conversar del tema nos
acompaña desde buenos aires soy
florencia de esperón ella es directora
de políticas en género y diversidad del
ministerio de transporte de argentina
florencia bienvenida de ella soy y somos
las mujeres menos capaces a la hora de
conducir un vehículo eso es lo que nos
dicta la creencia cultural en argentina
el hombre que
de manejar es una nena sin embargo que
nos dicen los índices de accidentalidad
hola angela muchas gracias por la
invitación para este en este espacio
para reflexionar acerca de los
siniestros viales que suceden en
argentina
como bien me preguntabas de la evidencia
y la estadística nos dicen que el 85% de
los accidentes viales las víctimas son
varones y que ese 15% restante que están
involucradas mujeres muchas de ellas no
conducían al momento del siniestro vial
por lo tanto y por otras cuestiones que
suceden como por ejemplo cuando se hace
el test de alcoholemia principalmente 5
de cada 100 varones da positivo cuando
sólo 07 de cada 100 mujeres da positivo
entonces las estadísticas nos demuestran
que hay una desigualdad y no quiere
decir que las mujeres conduzcamos mejor
sino que somos más capaces de acatar la
norma de tránsito porque no estamos
atravesadas por el estereotipo que si
están atravesados los varones de como
observaron en la vía pública
mire es que el acoso afecta a todas las
áreas de nuestra vida como mujeres y eso
no tiene excepción en la vida estamos
nosotros más expuestas a sufrir ataques
o robos solamente por ser mujeres a ser
intimidadas que podemos hacer
y así es así no sólo como usuarias de
vehículos o como conductoras sino
también como usuarias de los servicios
de transporte público desde el
ministerio de transporte de la nación
argentina de la mano de nuestro ministro
que se llama alexis guerrera venimos
desarrollando una agenda muy valiosa
donde estamos de alguna manera poniendo
en agenda pública todos estos temas
generando campañas de concientización de
difusión y de acompañamiento a las
mujeres que son víctimas de violencia en
la vía pública y en los sistemas de
transporte asimismo como otras acciones
que tienen que ver con la inclusión de
mujeres en espacios que históricamente
eran masculinizados dentro del sector
transporte bueno y adicionalmente a eso
[Música]
una persona al volante es responsable
por su vida por la vida de sus pasajeros
y los hay por la vida de las que van
caminando por la calle y de los otros
conductores entonces es realmente
importante incluir estas capacitaciones
de género para que el espacio público
sea más amigable y sobre todo lo más
seguro para todos
si es así nosotros apuntamos a que aquí
está esta concientización es una etapa
de cambio cultural es una instancia
educativa no tiene que ver con una
posición no nos queremos dejar a la
gente sin obtener la licencia pero sí
queremos aprovechar esta instancia para
poder reflexionar para poder crecer como
sociedad pero principalmente para
llevarnos el aprendizaje de que
necesitamos tener un espacio público una
vía pública y un sistema de transporte
libre de violencia y más justo para
todos y para todas
florencia hay además otro asunto y es
que por el sistema patriarcal en el que
vivimos las tareas de cuidado se nos
atribuyen a nosotras las que cuidamos
los hijos las que hacemos las compras e
igual tenemos que ir a trabajar y cuidar
la salud y el bienestar del resto de la
familia no le parece que esta iniciativa
es una oportunidad para dar un paso
adelante y concedernos a las mujeres el
respeto que necesitamos y merecemos en
la vida para así mismo poder proteger a
los nuestros ya otra cosa es que las
tareas de la familia deberían ser
siempre compartidas
y así es estamos en en argentina en un
proceso muy interesante de reflexión
acerca de los cuidados
también estamos reflexionando acerca de
que las mujeres sólo tenemos el 30 por
ciento de las licencias de conducir
sabemos que cuando hay en el hogar
generalmente es todo por el hombre en el
caso de una familia compuesta por para
una mujer y tus citas entonces también
tenemos que que las licencias también
la constante florencia sigue siendo en
todos los casos que le he preguntado el
temor de ser una mujer en un ambiente
que nos han convencido es mejor dominado
por los hombres sin embargo ya lo dijo
el ministro de transporte argentino y
nos lo repitió usted también las mujeres
tenemos una mayor tendencia a respetar
las normas de tránsito hablemos un poco
más de esto
y realmente nuestra pregunta tiene que
ver con esto con acatar las normas de
tránsito
los varones tiene interferencias a
utilizar medios el cinturón de seguridad
ha de salir y utilizar lo que es la
principal la de muerte de jóvenes de
entre 18 y 24 años en todo el mundo de
jóvenes varones entonces por esa
iniciativa y por esa razón hemos
desarrollado esta instancia que acompaña
tienda general que venimos desarrollando
desde el ministerio de transporte nas
bueno y ahora ya para ser más operativos
le quiero preguntar sobre los pormenores
de la medida qué pasa si una persona se
niega por ejemplo a tomar este para esta
parte del curso de conducción con la
capacitación de género
qué pasa si se niegan y sobre todo cómo
animar a que más mujeres se decidan a ir
por su licencia
bueno en realidad este esta iniciativa
no aplica dentro del examen de conducir
si se pasa un audiovisual un vídeo que
dura 7 minutos nada más y una pequeña
conversación con él con la persona que
facilita esta información así que es muy
corto no no hemos tenido ninguna
resistencia al respecto y es una
instancia de reflexión puede la persona
irse pensando que no está de acuerdo
pero pero si lo tiene que hacer esto se
está haciendo en todos los centros de
emisión de licencia que responden a la
agencia nacional de seguridad vial en
todo el territorio nacional argentino
que como saben es una extensión de
inmensa y de alguna manera para alentar
a que las mujeres con buscamos mejor y
conozcamos más en realidad estamos
también desarrollando junto con otros
ministerios de gobiernos como hace el
ministerio de trabajo de la nación
iniciativas que beneficien
principalmente los costos económicos
para
las licencias profesionales de conducir
y que dentro de poco en argentina
tengamos más mujeres conduciendo
colectivos buses camiones y por qué no
trenes
mire argentino ha sido una de las
banderas del feminismo en américa latina
y esta iniciativa que ustedes tienen
ahora es aplaudida porque hasta el
momento es al parecer única en su género
al menos en la región a mí en colombiano
me tocó ahora las argentinas y los
argentinos tendrán que pensarlo y sería
un buen ejemplo para otros países para
que siguieran sus pasos así que serán
medidos con una vara muy alta
bueno esperemos que realmente la
experiencia de argentina pueda servir a
otros sistemas de transporte de los
países de principalmente de américa
latina' realmente nosotros estamos a
disposición para poder contar cómo ha
sido a esta instancia de poder generar
también porque ha sido bien compleja por
porque todas las personas que facilitan
este contenido tuvieron que tener una
capacitación previa así que realmente la
iniciativa ha sido como compleja en su
implementación pero realmente estamos
muy convencidos y convencidas de que
debemos resguardar la vida por sobre
todas las cosas y que derribando
estereotipos es la primera manera en la
que construimos una sociedad más justa
igualitaria así que esperemos que más
países de la región se sumen a esta
iniciativa esperemos que sí gracias a
ustedes florencia por estar con nosotros
o sea nuestros televidentes sigan en
france24 y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]